bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être venu en direct ce matin avec nous
sur rt français les organisateurs ont
dévoilé la date de cette primaire hier
ce sera donc le 16 janvier prochain
écoutez leurs motivations et on en parle
après il ya des parties des acteurs
politiques qui aujourd'hui ont fait une
croix sur 2022 ne croit pas en la
possibilité de gagner cette élection
nous ce qu'on dit c'est quand m et nos
vies c'est 50 nos vies qui sont en jeu
il ya une urgence écologique et sociale
qui est partagé par tout le monde tout
le monde l'a constaté tout le monde l'a
sens mais que pourtant personnes
s'organisent pour vraiment être capable
de prendre le pouvoir d'arriver à
l'elysée et d'engager une bifurcation
écologique et sociale de la france alors
qu'on n'a pas cinq ans et qu'il faut le
faire dès 2022 alors voilà pour le
constat voilà pourquoi organiser cette
initiative citoyenne jacques boutault
quel est votre sentiment sur cet oeil du
siat yves
je pense qu on n'a pas le choix quant au
résultat c'est à dire que si on veut que
la gauche gagne cette élection
présidentielle elle doit y aller unis
aujourd'hui tous les sondages se disant
une gauche unie l'état 25% sans
dynamique donc elle serait encore plus
haute avec une dynamique gagnante et
donc elle peut s'inscrire au deuxième
tour et l'emporter il n'ya pas d'autre
voie que l'union donc un tampon cette
voie et faisons tout pour y parvenir on
va en parler plus en détail oui je vous
en prie non j'allais dire que le chien
allait difficile et j'allais dire que en
quelque sorte la pente est rude mais la
ligne droite on va en parler en est
ailleurs c'est vrai qu'il ya 130 mille
inscrits c'est même mieux que la
primaire les verts n'ont que vous avez
organisé de l'autre côté votre sentiment
romain colas au parti socialiste on en
pense quoi
on aurait vu très objectivement d'un
assez bon oeil qu'on puisse trouver
primaires populaires pas les voies et
moyens pour que
la gauche en tout cas ce blog social
écologique dont nous considérons qu'il
est effectivement ça a été dit dans
votre reportage d'ailleurs ce qui est
indispensable pour les prochaines années
pour engager les mutations nécessaires
sans délaisser la question sociale qui
revient sur le devant de la scène de la
scène politique nous aurions aimé que
nous trouvions les voies et moyens pour
organiser les conditions d'un
rassemblement avec une candidature
unique de ce bloc est d'ailleurs le ps
très franchement si vous voulez si vous
voulez annonce
conditions c'est pas la meilleure façon
de procéder c'est la raison pour
laquelle olivier faur particulièrement
mais l'ensemble du parti socialiste ces
derniers mois même site deux dernières
années ont plaidé auprès des formations
politiques de la gauche pour que celle
ci crée les conditions de ce
rassemblement force est de constater que
malheureusement nous a claqué la porte
au nez la plupart du temps jean luc
mélenchon et ça ne nous a pas
franchement étonné connaissant le
personnage a été le premier à dire que
quoi qu'il arrive
on est qui serait évidemment candidat
puis ont suivi europe ecologie les verts
portés c'est vrai par des percées
électorales lors des scrutins européens
et locaux ban a souhaité s'engager là
aussi dans une démarche centrée sur le
parti au motif qu' il considère que
désormais le leadership à gauche leur
leur appartient et donc nous avons été
les seuls pendant de longs mois a plaidé
pour que ce rassemblement dès le 1er
tour puisse s'opérer
désormais le calendrier est lancé dans
48 heures maintenant dans moins de 48
heures les socialistes s'apprêtent à
voter pour désigner à leur tour leur
candidate ou leur candidat à l'élection
présidentielle ce le sera selon toute
vraisemblance anne hidalgo et j'ai
tendance à dire que malheureusement nous
sommes à un moment où les partis autour
de nous se sont repliés sur eux mêmes
ont souhaité s'engager dans une démarche
d'affirmation de leur identité propre et
que les conditions de ce rassemblement à
l'heure où nous parlons ne sont pas
réunies le train est lancé et que au
moment où la primaire populaire se
prononcera le 15 janvier on verra ce
qu'il en est dans les camps passion dans
l'opinion mais chacun sera parti en
campagne et je ne vois pas comment ça
pourra influer sur la suite du scrutin
ce que je crois c'est que nous avons
intérêt et vous avez compris que je
souhaite que ce soit au tour d'anne
hidalgo que cela s'opère qu'un
rassemblement qu'une dynamique secret
autour d'un des candidats d'une des
candidates de ce bloc social écologique
sera peut-être les autres à à réfléchir
ou pas au maintien de leur candidature
en tout cas malheureusement train est
lancé alors le problème jacques boutault
de cette primaire citoyenne c'est qu'il
y ait des personnalités qui ne sont même
pas candidat à l'écouté christiane
taubira par exemple
je ne peux pas venir contribuer à
l'éparpillement parce que je ne peux pas
dire que notre chance est de sortir de
la confusion et dire que moi aussi je
viens apporter mon obole mais je ne veux
pas rester une observatrice de cette
campagne d'une façon ou d'une autre je
vais trouver ma place alors elle figure
parmi les personnalités qui ont été
plébiscités par par les citoyens qui ont
voté alors que qu'est ce que ça veut
dire as qu'elle elle refuse elle ne sera
pas candidat mais est ce que ça veut
dire qu un autre candidat peut émerger
qui n'est pas encore candidat
aujourd'hui
non je crois que ce que ça veut dire
c'est que
il faut que les organisateurs de cette
primaire citoyenne
prennent conscience que ça ne peut
fonctionner que si les candidats
potentiels ou putatifs sont volontaires
pour que ça fonctionne et c'est
peut-être aujourd'hui la première limite
en tout cas la plus importante est
peut-être l'unique même d'ailleurs de
cette primaire parce que en ce qui
concerne les candidats eux-mêmes pour
répondre à un romain colas j'aurais
peut-être envie de lui dire quand il ya
la volonté ya le chemin certes les
désignations des partis politiques sont
en cours mais qu'il y ait une sélection
au sein des partis et d'ailleurs je
rappelle aussi que europe écologie les
verts a fait sa sélection de façon très
large puisque delphine batho bateau
pardon et jean marc governatori
n'appartiennent pas à europe ecologie
les verts c'est donc avec tout l'arc
écologique que son candidat était
choisie il peut y avoir après la
désignation par le parti socialiste un
deuxième temps dans lequel les candidats
qui veulent cette union pour gagner
et bien se mettre d'accord via
une primaire populaire qui soit celle
organisée par les les citoyens qui l'ont
prise en charge pour sam at-il dit mr en
particulier on ne citer qu'elles c'est
une très bonne initiative mais qui doit
pouvoir s'exercer
uniquement qui pourra s'exercer
uniquement si les candidats sont
volontaires pour jouer le jeu jusqu'au
bout et ça c'est pas encore complètement
exclue malgré tout ce qu'on dit sur jean
luc mélenchon écoutez moi je crois qu on
dit beaucoup de choses vraies fausses
sur jean luc mélenchon mais je crois que
c'est foncièrement quelqu'un qui certes
un ego surdimensionné mais comment faire
de la politique sans avoir des goûts
mais ces ouvriers il ya des degrés
ailleurs est ce que c'est un combat qui
perce le ch est aussi un combat d'idées
voilà mais c'est quelqu'un de très
intelligent et qui peut comprendre que
c'est un débat d'idées et qui pourrait
en cas de victoire de la gauche jouer un
rôle institutionnel très intéressant par
exemple je me suggère et je vais déjà
suggéré par un intermédiaire en
s'occupant de la sixième république
puisque lui théorie ce que les
que dans que dans une république
vraiment démocratique ceux qui font de
la république ne peuvent pas la diriger
donc celui qui fonderait ceux qui font
brûler les députés les citoyens et les
élus qui fonderait la république futur
ne pourrait pas la diriger donc offrons
lui la possibilité de fond des arrêts de
travail est à être président de la la
fondation de la 6ème république
et ça lui permettrait d'avoir un rôle
institutionnel fondamentales sans être
président de la république parce
qu'aujourd'hui je pense que c'est une
personnalité trop clivant
malheureusement peut-être mais c'est
ainsi pour l'être en revanche président
de la république en revanche c'est
quelqu'un qui peut jouer un rôle
fondamental pour la france pour sortir
la france de l'ornière
écologique et sociale dans laquelle
aujourd'hui elle est anti c'est alors
les les candidats l'espoir vous avez de
l'espoir alors il ya beaucoup de
candidats et c'est effectivement qui
n'ont pas forcément envie d'y aller
pourtant même à droite xavier bertrand
lui s'est rangé à l'idée du congrès pour
mener pour pour désigner un candidat
unique à droite regardez ce qu'on a dit
pierre larrouturou il est organisateur
de cette primaire citoyenne
hier matin xavier bertrand n'était pas
candidat à la primaire de la droite il a
changé d'avis de même yannick jadot et
anne hidalgo devrait comprendre que
cette primaire populaire est le seul
moyen pour gagner en 2022 si l'extrême
droite est à 16% se qualifier pour le
second tour est possible donc on a un
cola est ce que c'est une leçon à tirer
même xavier bertrand a fait marche
arrière
et xavier bertrand il est candidat a pas
une primaire de rassemblement de
différentes formations politiques de
sensibilités et les candidats à la
primaire d'un parti qui est celle des
républicains en fait on assiste un
processus chez les républicains qui est
identique à celui même si le périmètre
électoral n'est pas le même auquel on a
assisté chez europe ecologie les verts
auquel on assiste sera demain au parti
socialiste avec des militants qui vont
voter on était dans une primaire plus
ouverte europe ecologie les verts enfin
la droite et le centre excusez moi c'est
clr
moi j'ai jamais j'ai jamais compris
d'ailleurs ce qu'était le centre dans ce
pays le chantre il est tout jeune
ghoulam toujours avec à droite donc il
est ni de gauche ni de gauche donc c'est
un peu plus à droite travaux la salle le
spectre à gauche est beaucoup trop large
en termes de d'idées pour faire de m en
tout cas il ya aujourd'hui à mon sens
c'est sûr et c'est là dessus qu'on peut
se fera pas avec jacky ya trop de
candidats la gauche moi ce que j'ai
envie de dire c'est malheureusement le
train est parti encore une fois le parti
socialiste a plaidé pendant de longs
mois sans être entendus pour on trouve
les voies et moyens de désigner une
candidature commune maintenant ce sont
les électeurs qui vont avoir à trancher
à mon sens même si je regarde évidemment
avec beaucoup de bienveillance parce que
ça correspondait à un idéal que de
portions cette primaire populaire ce que
je veux dire surtout aux françaises et
aux français qui en sincérité s'engagent
dans cette démarche de la primaire
populaire c'est qu'on voit qu'on a on a
encore des partis politiques même s'ils
ont été affaiblis
avec le bouleversement
politique de qui structurent la vie
politique française et il concourt
d'ailleurs c'est ce que dit notre
constitution à l'expression à
l'expression du suffrage et que c'est
parti pour peser sur eux c'est bien de
faire une primaire populaire l'extérieur
c'est encore mieux d'être à l'intérieur
peut être que si on avait eu plus de
militants de cette primaire populaire
chez europe écologie les verts à la
france insoumise
à oopa sa coupe un petit peu romain
colas qu'on aurait pu faire entendre
raison à un certain nombre de leaders
alors jacques bardy faisait que j'invite
les je vous en prie
je disais que j'invite donc un maximum
de nos concitoyens et de nos concitoyens
et qui se revendique de cette gauche de
ce bloc social écologique aussi à
investir les formations politiques parce
qu'on a besoin de cette régénération à
l'intérieur des formations et peut-être
que s'il avait été de nombreux membres
de la france un soumises d'europe
écologie les verts ou encore du ps nous
n'en serions pas là aujourd'hui a
constaté malheureusement cet émiettement
espace aussi dans les partis politiques
c'est ça que je veux dire d'accord
jacques boutault un espoir les candidats
à gauche ont quand même signé un socle
commun de propositions à l'initiative de
de ce collectif citoyen c'est
encourageant
oui mais je te dire qui là dessus je
crois que europe écologie les verts fait
le taf comme on dit fait le boulot et je
rappelle quand même que europe écologie
les verts et son candidat yannick jadot
s'était effacée dans en 2010 est
dernière benoît hamon que yannick jadot
a pris l'initiative avant la primaire
des écologistes pour rassembler
l'ensemble de la gauche est d'ailleurs
la france a subi cité présente puisque
eric coquerel qui est quand même une
personnalité de la france insoumise
étaient présents entre autres et landes
oui mais c'est déjà bien c'est un début
et malheureusement il n'ya pas de suite
là dessus c'est pas et or
malheureusement anne hidalgo a dit
qu'elle n'y était pas favorable donc
c'est pas faux pas renvoyer la balle
dans le camp de l'adversaire pour qu'on
est soi-même
pas dans le jeu quoi si je puis dire je
crois qu'il faut qu'on soit tous en
capacité de pouvoir se parler et qu'on
fasse le meilleur choix et ceux
meilleurs choix ce sera les citoyens eux
mêmes qui le feront en décidant lors
d'une primaire ouverte je pense que la
la la la la la méthode est la bonne même
s'il faut un peu la peau chiner et
surtout avoir la pièce mans des
candidats potentiels enfin colas est ce
que ça la planète par exemple ou est ce
que ce sera fait par exemple de vote
je vous en prie il reste très peu de
temps est ce que ce seront les sondages
qui délimiteront peut-être un candidat
unique selon vous romain colas il ne
reste que quelques secondes bah je pense
que si effectivement et vous avez
compris quel est mon souhait s'il ya une
candidate ou un candidat mais je
préférerais que ce soit une candidate
qui qui est qui qui entre en dynamique
dans ce que j'appelle la social-écologie
ce blog qui aspire de toutes façons de
marc gouverner ensemble
eh bien ça incitera les uns et les
autres arts et envisager la pertinence
ou pas de leur candidature et à ce que
ce dialogue qui n'a pas pu aller
jusqu'au bout malheureusement avant que
ces candidatures n'existe puis ce
pourquoi pas se prolonger et oui les
sondages vont avoir un moment où
l'opinion commencera à se cristalliser
parce qu'aujourd'hui je pense qu'il
sondage ne valent rien très honnêtement
c'est celui qui parle le plus fort celui
qui a la plus grande exposition
médiatique qui aujourd'hui peut faire
des percées vous voyez qu'elle
examinait les sondages 2 5% à 17 tout
ceci d'une volatilité extrême ne veut
rien dire on voit zemmour à la télé par
taux bas demain on verra yannick jadot
on verra l'année d'algos parce qu'ils
vont dynamiser leur campagne elle va
monter en puissance et oui alors un
rendez vous sans doute au au début de
l'année pour regarder où on en est et
puis chacune et chacun aux
responsabilités fera ses choix mais il
ya une détermination chez anne hidalgo
qui est puissante merci beaucoup merci à
tous les deux merci romain colas merci à
vous que j'ai le butoh d'avoir participé
à ce débat en direct sur arte france